fifteen year old boy in California who's
telling us how his father was shot and
killed in front of him on a fourth of
July trip Ari and Jack Gershwin asked a
man for directions last Friday near down
evil around two hours north of
Sacramento and then with no warning the
man opened fire and Ari was hit and that
was just the beginning of Jack's ordeal
in an interview you'll only see on CBS
this morning Jack and his mother tell us
their family's new reality still hasn't
sunk in and a Warner has his story I
said where's dad and he's like he's been
shot and I said what do you what do you
even mean when Paige Gershman received
text messages from her son Jack on
Friday she says she thought he was
sending her videos of scenery from a
trip with his dad in California's Tahoe
National Forest but the teen was
reaching out with a far more harrowing
message Jack said his father dr. Ari
Gershman had been shot and killed by a
gunman my dad suggested asking for
directions
the shooter pulls out a pistol and
starts shooting after two or three shots
he was hit the 15 year old says he
bolted from the car and took off into
the surrounding woods near the poker
flat area of Sierra County Jack says he
got lost and when he was finally able to
call his mom he barely had reception and
his phone was running out of battery
when my phone died local authorities say
it was more than 30 hours until they
were able to locate Jack and reunite him
with his family we all just screamed
that relief later that day
law-enforcement detained the suspected
gunman 40 year-old Jon Thomas Conway the
Sierra County Sheriff's Office says he's
suspected of shooting and wounding two
other people in a separate attack the
motive for both shootings is unknown I
just now dr. Gershman s family is
remembering a man they called humble
smart and generous he was all about
helping others and just so funny any
kind it's just my best friend Paige
Gershman told us the police are going to
be asking her son Jack to look at a
lineup today this now widowed mother of
three is currently undergoing
chemotherapy for cancer
a GoFundMe page for the family has
already raised more than four hundred
thirty thousand dollars Tony she's quite
a suspect too easy in custody Anna thank
you very much